president Trump hitting the campaign
trail in Ohio over the weekend and
predicting a possible red wave in the
midterms this comes ahead of a hotly
contested special election in the
Buckeye States 12th district tomorrow
they're talking about this blue wave I
don't think so you win and you're a
little complacent but I mean that was
two years ago so I just said why but we
have the greatest economy in the history
of our country we have things that have
never happened look if the Democrats get
in they're gonna raise your taxes you
could have crime all over the place
you're gonna have people pouring across
the border so why would that be a blue
wave I think it could be a red wave the
economy is a big plus for the president
a three point nine percent unemployment
rate is the lowest for a July of a
midterm year since 1966 meanwhile
Democrats are taking a different
approach senator Kamala Harris is
speaking out against the use of this
political phrase I have a problem guys
with that phrase identity politics
because let's be clear when people say
that it's a pejorative that phrase is
used to divide and it is used to
distract its purpose is to minimize and
marginalize issues that impact all of us
it is used to try and shut us up all
right Greg I have to go to you on that
because you talked a lot about identity
politics and now that helps divide the
country and she's saying it's actually
if you say that then you're being
divisive well here's that was a very
powerful I mean if you agree with her
she's very persuasive I have to say
she's a strong speaker I do disagree
with everything she's saying but I have
to say the way she said it was pretty
strong identity politics used to be a
rallying cry for the left it was a
positive thing now when you mention it
it's an insult and the reason is is
because ultimately the consequences of
identity politics is putting the group
before the individual and what happens
is everybody who are in their specific
groups then have to feel that their
group
somehow more important in the other
group so what you end up having or
warring factions and you're seeing it a
lot of times where one group accuses
another group of cultural appropriation
and then another group accused that
group of something else ultimately it's
gonna turn on itself this is why Trump
won was because he was talking about one
identity politic which was American now
then you have the left saying no that's
racist because what you're really saying
is white when you're talking about
America that's the consequence of
identity politics is what they're saying
is that if you are white you are part of
the oppressor group and it's the ident
and so when you say identity politics
you're obviously racist so that's
nothing good can come from identity
politics because in its heart it's about
division Sammy and welcome to the fire
thank you quite a different message
right so President Trump said a rally
that's a different scene for him he
loves it he's into the crowd
can you contrast' that with Kamala
Harris who was giving a speech at
Netroots nation what do you think about
the way that they're both setting things
up
well her attempt to retreat from
identity politics which they've relied
on for decades tells you that they've
noticed it's not working they've seen
something internally that tells them
we've got to stop this and actually an
independent woman's voice which I'm the
president and McLaughlin's survey shows
that 85% of people don't care as an
example about gender they're not going
to base their vote on gender and yet
that's what all of 2016 was really vote
for Hillary will be the first woman
president or vote for this person it'll
be the first of this thing or the other
thing Americans are not caring because
they've realized that that's false it
doesn't work so her position is well
this is now not working we've relied on
this let's retreat a bit the president
just being consistent it was what the
campaign was we're all in this together
the numbers prove that's correct all of
the unemployment numbers we know of
course are extraordinary now that
everyone's boat has been lifted it's the
thing that he promised and it's based on
all of us actually not seeing each other
differently but seeing each other as a
neighbor
that's what resonates with the American
people and that's why it's working
Richard I imagine you disagree okay I'll
give you the floor you can tell us why
don't give in the floor just give me the
table okay in the table for $200 so
here's my take on this so I
I think what senator Harris is trying to
say then she said it very eloquently is
this when you fix an issue that's for
example plaguing the african-american
community you help all Americans when
you properly fund public education you
help all Americans when you fix our
broken immigration system you help all
Americans when you make sure that
everybody has the right to vote without
in front without disenfranchisement you
help all Americans so it's not identity
policies make sure that America works
for everybody no matter their color no
matter their race no matter their
sexuality no matter their zip code and I
think that's the fight that Democrats I
think we have what we have in the White
House is a president who won't even
acknowledge at Pride Month is a thing
and we're still fighting for LGBTQ
rights right you have a president in the
White House well so accepting gay
marriage before Obama did but you also
have a president the White House who
gets in fights with NFL players or gets
in fights with LeBron James because he
opened up a school he also gets a fight
with the fights with Hillary Clinton he
gets in fights with everybody gets a try
to Rosie O'Donnell that doesn't hurt any
particular group if he's fighting with
some well I think if you I think if you
talk to the African American community
they would say when you pick when you
pick on LeBron James for opening a
school in Akron Ohio you're picking on
the entire African American community
because he opened up a school he picked
on him because LeBron James picked on
Donald Trump and that's everybody and
also it was to make fun of Don Lemon
doesn't take the high road he gets in
the dirt sit down just say okay but you
should be used to it it's two years
piling on eight
I think the identity politics thing is
they're looking for differences as Tammy
said instead of everything that unites
us and the Democratic Party they have
coalition's and they group these
coalition's together for electoral
victories based on their identity and
what they do is they have these groups
and they say these groups have
grievances and we are going to correct
those grievances we are going to right
those wrongs or right those and justices
and we're going to take and use the
government to do that by redistributing
wealth and benefits but what they do is
they say everything that's wrong that's
plaguing these identity groups is the
fault of Republicans it's not the
group's fault it's not the economy's
fault it's not something that has
nothing to do with
Republicans it's all the Republicans
fault so they demonize the Republicans
and create a war there's a war on women
there's a were minorities there's a war
on Muslims and a lot of Republicans
don't go out every day and wake up you
breakfast and say how can I wage war on
other people in this country and I go to
work they get their money and they don't
want the government to keep all pieces
of sound for you and control I'm gonna
ask you to play these thoughts back to
back one is a Senate candidate
Republican Senate candidate in Michigan
that primary election is tomorrow and
the other is from you know her well
Alexandria Acacio Cortes who was in the
same state of Michigan campaigning for
somebody else over the weekend I don't
have a black message I don't have a
white message I have a red white and
blue message I have a message of
everybody achieving the American dream
we can say that a Muslim man can be the
first governor that can be the first
Muslim governor in this country in the
Midwest and we don't have to be afraid
of some other that won't vote for him
because we know that 10 years ago they
voted for a man named Barack Hussein
Obama tell me your thoughts on that look
and she uses it right there's just some
other casting immediately everyone else
says the other now look this is why it's
not working and why senator Harris's is
troubled the Harvard Harris poll showed
a 10 percent 10-point boost of approval
for the president by Hispanics and
Rasmussen is showing last year the
president was at 15% of approval amongst
African Americans today he's at 29
percent so you're looking at a
trajectory where groups that have been
protected are saying wait a minute we
are the same the the money is the same
the the amount of money that we're
getting and from the tax cuts that we've
got a job that's actually not delivering
pizza it's actually a real good I mean
we're getting shot in the street by
police with no accountability when are
we being for wherever you've been
protected you're that's not true by the
way there's a lot of accountability why
don't you look at why don't you look at
the research look at the research
waiting look at the research of who's
doing the shooting Richard you could
slip that in but that good example right
now with those numbers for
african-americans we immediately go to
fear and victimhood that's what we're
rejecting oh because yeah
very fearful when I get pulled by the
police I'm very fearful right so here's
the here's the bottom line we're talking
about identity politics let's say you
haven't you want to have a discussion
with somebody about identity politics
and you say I'm willing to listen to you
and I want to know and I agree with you
what do you get you you don't get the
answer because it's never enough the
idea of identity politics as to that as
you are the oppressor and they are the
oppressed so there's actually no end in
sight so if you say will you take our
help I would like to help you with this
that will not be enough if you see any
any public disturbance between either
wits anti-fog
or activists these are these are people
who are not interested in to discussion
all right so that's why people say when
they're talking about identity politics
they can't have a discussion because it
never ends they're never happy that any
identity politics is not about solutions
all right it's about but undoing
civilization but especially a prism and
that was a red herring because that same
art can be made about the KKK they're
not trying to have a discussion with me
about how to be less racist I agree with
you there so the boys like the KKK
that's not a red herring talk to
everyday African Americans they would
say or you talk to her everyday brown
folks they would say high quality
neighborhood public schools investments
in our community opportunities in our
community we're still fighting for that
everybody's fighting one last thing
which is at President Trump he has a way
of basically disrupting everything so
you have Republicans across the country
trying to lower expectations going into
Ohio 12:00 tomorrow so that they could
hopefully you know beat expectation he
says he's just forget all that he's like
but he's raising expectations and
expecting a red wave in November they
need a red wall because it shouldn't be
this close here in Ohio this is a
district that they've won the
Republicans I think for decades going
back to the 30s now it's tied you know
the Democrats running away from Nancy
Pelosi he's keeping it on kitchen table
issues education costs and health care
costs and he doesn't even really mention
Donald Trump that much the Republican is
a little bit older not as charismatic so
he's got a little personality problem
there Alicia now the
national media is coming in big-time
they started going positive and touting
the president's success and now they're
just smearing this Democrat they're
linking him to Elizabeth Warren calling
her Pocahontas they're going dirty late
so that means they're worried about it
but I think the Republicans gonna hang
on but if the Democrat does win it's
going to give the Democrats a lot of
momentum going in and get this who no
matter what happens tomorrow they both
run again against each other in November
so we'll be back talking about Ohio 12th